you're all set
thank you
so to open the meeting i have a script
to uh
to read in order to uh
comply with the public meeting
requirements uh as chair of the house
commerce and consumer affairs
[Music]
to committee
comply with the public meeting
requirements feedback
yeah
and consumer affairs committee
can we uh
find a way to get rid of that echo
all right
um
as chair of the house commerce and
consumer affairs committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the covid
19 pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contin
contemporaneously
to this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that we
are
[Music]
with provision a providing public access
to the meeting by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and select staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address
https
colon forward slash forward slash zoom
dot u s
forward slash j forward slash
983-879-30737
or dialing one of the following phone
numbers one three one two
six two six
six seven nine nine
or 1929-205-6099
provision b providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
excuse me
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting including how to
access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar
provision c providing a mechanism for
the public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if anybody has a problem please call 271
3600 or email at hcs
leg.state
and provision d
adjourning the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting in the
event the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us
pam smarling is the meeting host
additional staff providing support are
christina dyer and brad greenland thank
you very much for your support
especially ms marling who has
organized all of this for us
this is a work session on bills referred
to the commerce committee for interim
study an executive session will follow
and we are following each bill
discussion with the executive vote
motion and vote
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website under the heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
and let's start the meeting by taking
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
that's the end of that screen
ms uh representative weston if you would
uh do a roll call
of course
vice chairman william
i am president in my home in wilton and
i'm alone except for my cockatiel
uh representative gage
not here not present
representative abel
a representative abel i am
here
in
west lebanon new hampshire by myself
uh representative bartlett
not here
representative herbert
also not here right here
representative macbeth
representative macbeth is here in her
office in portsmouth new hampshire
representative van houghton
i'm you
my apologies i am home i am in my study
in manchester new hampshire and i am
alone and i apologize for not on meeting
representative fargo
um i'm in my home in dover new hampshire
i'm alone
representative indrip
i am present calling in from nashua new
hampshire and i am alone
representative weston
i am representative weston i'm in
plymouth in my upstairs office and my
dog is with me
representative hunt
i am here i am again in uh wikipog rhode
island and i am all by myself
representative sanborn
not here
representative osborne
also not here
representative plummer
i am here in my home office in belmont
new hampshire and i'm alone
representative barnes
i am here in my home office in salem and
i am alone
representative patusik
i am here in derry new hampshire
upstairs in my hobby room i am by myself
representative warden
don't see you on and off
myself
thank you and share butler
i am here in my home office in hart's
location and i am alone
13 here
thank you
and
uh today we are going to as we did
yesterday discuss and vote on uh the
remaining bills uh that we
referred for interim study
um
and we will have that discussion among
uh the committee members open it up to
the public and i understand there are a
number of people who may want to comment
on our bills
um and uh then we will make a motion and
vote on each bill
as after it is discussed
and uh let's begin with house bill 462
which is relative to digital electronic
product repair
and uh representative williams you can
raise your hand um today uh in order to
make the
identification of people who want to
speak easier
and at this moment i don't see any
hands-raised
representative indrik
do you have
thoughts about
this bill
[Music]
sure mr jarrett thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
as i'm sure many of the committee
members will recall i actually wrote the
committee reports
on this earlier and we had some
residents i
certainly did about
the breadth of this bill as written
and some of this potential security and
privacy issues uh as well as issues
related to digital rights management and
a few other
uh more technical questions uh all that
being said uh i think many of us and i
know myself certainly included
had a lot of sympathy
with the idea and the intent behind this
bill
and i personally think
it would be worthy to explore
a more limited bill
perhaps one that targets say personal
uh portable electronic devices uh at a
certain price point or above that would
limit the application of the bill
potentially also to
portions of those device that are more
likely to fail
such as the screen charging port
or
other
typical failure points
that are real sore points for new
hampshire consumers
and that it seems could potentially
balance some of the security concerns uh
as well as some of the other
consumer protection elements
thank you for that and um i would uh
support that and i'm disappointed that
you're not going to be running again
um and uh as as you know neither am i so
neither of us will be able to
uh put that bill in but i hope you will
help me
in finding
the advocates that
would consider
supporting that
process as you know
we have a
business up here in
my valley um
that
does provide
services for personal portable
electronic devices um including uh
iphones um even though that is
somewhat
illegal
and
they have a
thriving business and it just doesn't
make sense not to
[Music]
find a way to
support that
business
[Music]
representative macbeth i see your hand
up
thank you
care butler i appreciate it
this is an issue that um i was grateful
to learn more about this year and i too
visited um a couple of the stores or
retail operations that are repairing
some of the portable devices one here in
portsmouth and was very impressed and um
what representative endrick said about
you know tailoring this bill a little
bit more to some of the
uh
specific needs that we did here from um
you know new hampshire citizens
very interested and would like to see
this go forward and working with all the
stakeholders to kind of make it
good for consumers but perhaps something
that
they can get on board with thank you
thank you representative macbeth
representative
williams thank you mr chairman um so i
would agree with what everybody said so
far i think supporting our local small
businesses is always important
um
i i recognize though that this is a
something of a national effort
some of the people who spoke uh both for
and against uh were not from new
hampshire
and and i would hope that we would work
with this national group
um
i'd rather not see new hampshire be the
pioneers i think that's kind of where we
were before
um and
hopefully you know this will get through
uh some other legislation some other
legislators
before
we do it again just so that we can
maybe
say hey other states are doing it as
well because i do think
you know there's no difference between
how new hampshire
wants to handle its
device repair and how
some other state
thank you
representative hunt
thank you mr chair so did california
pass something or didn't wasn't there a
referendum or something that california
passed something am i remembering the
right issue here
i'm not aware of it
representative endrick are you do you
know
i believe
i believe representative hunt might
actually be thinking about uh something
related to hb 1680 which we will discuss
later with regard to privacy and
personal information okay
i got him confused all right so um
i would say that this summer i've had a
little experience with uh cracked
screens
and um first it was my my uh my wife
linda's
iphone um
in which of course we do have the
warranty that it that they with it with
uh
um assertion uh you know which is a big
insurance company that uh does uh
cell phones um they have they have two
different ways to do it you pay them 27
if it's only just a crack screen there's
nothing wrong with the phone
uh so which we signed up for and we sent
it out out to them
and well actually don't say you they
send you a box and you put it in there
and you send it out to them
and they and uh they sent it back and
said so sorry um it's you know you can't
you can't use that there there there's
something wrong with the phone
so not that we could see anything wrong
with the phone we turned the phone on we
got to operate everything sees
everything fine i don't see any
scratches i don't see deaths i don't see
anything wrong with it so that means we
got to spend the 200
to get it
uh so which we then duly call them up
they sent us the little box they did
credit us for the 27 that we passed
before
uh and uh lo and behold the very next
day they did not wait to get that unit
the very next day we had a brand new
iphone delivered to us
so as far as i'm concerned if you're
gonna if you're gonna say well we're
gonna narrow it to crack screens
insurance thing works and i'll and i
really know that because
uh the other day or not less than a
month ago uh my old ipad and so it's
past warranty and stuff like that i was
in the bathroom and i pushed the little
button on the bottom and sure enough the
thing decided to do a somersault
and did i even though i have a
protective case around it i did did a
face plant on the bathroom floor and
sure enough the screen was hopelessly
cracked all over the place
so
uh i then called up the you know i said
what am i going to do who am i that's
not a warranty i don't have any extended
warranty i don't have anything on this
um but i do have a a
a third-party verizon store that's right
you know
a mile away from the house so i called
them up and they said oh yeah bring it
on in 200 bucks
and sure enough
i brought it in it took a little longer
because they don't have it in stock they
got to wait until it come comes in
and uh
but they finally came in they put it in
and it's all good and it's the exact
same price as the insurance one 200
bucks
so
is to say that uh
we're hoping that somehow we're going to
save money somehow or do something
different that the marketplace the free
market's already taken care of i don't
know what i heard in the testimony is
these guys want to get in there with a
soldering iron
and start mucking around with the
hardware
and i'm sorry i i think that a
manufacturer has a right to say we don't
want anybody
messing with our our motherboards or
hardware or anything like that and if
you do it you do it at your own risk
but you know with your your
you know the say is now they're on an
obligation to explain where everything
is and where it is and all their how
they do how they did that motherboard
and how they worked it um
i i just think it is incredibly
inappropriate for the legislature to be
involved in that i would say i also have
finished reading steve jobs book this
summer and as chiefs does make a very
convincing argument about why he thinks
it's important that if a company wants
to have a sealed box and and doesn't
want anybody mucking around with it um
that that's an important prior priority
you know
prior was a priority probably that was
the word i'm looking for right uh
private you know that they should have
they should be able to have that and and
for us to legislate that
um i just don't i just don't know how
it's going to be enforced are you going
to have called the ag's office and say
they won't they won't let me they won't
let somebody get a manual and and the ag
is going to get them call some
manufacturer and tell them to beat them
up for a manual and and worst of it is
what happens if this is a new hampshire
company what happens is there's somebody
doing high-tech stuff here right here in
hampshire i'm sure dean caiman probably
wouldn't be too crazy about anybody
getting inside some of the things he's
making
and i just think this this is totally
inappropriate legislation
thank you representative indrik do you
have further comments
well i think i have some sympathy with
what representative hunt is saying in
that i have elected
uh to participate in the apple ecosystem
in large part because i do believe
hopefully not inaccurately that it is in
some sense safer and more private than
some other systems which can be more
open and certainly that was one of the
concerns i had with regard to the
legislation that was before us the
specific legislation and the language
regarding um
security lockout codes and things of
that nature where where i do see
some potential problems uh both
philosophical and practical
but on a more concrete level i do think
we've all experienced cracked screens
and defective charging ports and things
that really seems like in many instances
can plausibly be
disaggregated and separated from
security issues i believe
and insofar as that is the case i think
it's reasonable for us to have these
discussions and to see what we can do to
try to ensure
uh that that products have a life
expectancy that uh the consumers expect
when they pay a thousand dollars for a
cell phone
and i think it is reasonable for us to
have this and certainly we've heard a
fair amount from the public for
ecological reasons for budgetary reasons
uh
for just a matter of principle that
there is a lot of demand for this and i
think it is valuable to have these
conversations and i would hope that the
legislator would be open to doing so
thank you representative abel
yes thank you um i think once again i
may be taking the minority position here
which is not unusual but uh and and i
don't exactly know how how everyone on
the committee will vote um
but i see the principal issue for me
being who i should represent and who i
am giving the highest priority to and i
see that as
the voters in my district who
live in new hampshire and who run
business small businesses in new
hampshire
and the corporations that are outside of
the state
have a sec i have no real responsibility
to them
and so therefore
i feel that we should commend this bill
with changes
uh so that small businesses
uh can compete if if i as a as an
individual decide i want to go to them
affect something as i do with my car i
don't have to go to the dealer i don't
have to take it back to detroit um or
send it to them um that we should we
should look
out first for
for new hampshire small businesses
that are competing against out-of-state
large corporations so i i support uh i
support us making a recommendation uh in
favor of passing
thank you
thank you representative abel
representative williams
thank you mr chairman um i
my attitude is if i buy something
um it's mine it no longer belongs to
apple or to
you know whoever manufactured it you
know i was willing to pay for it
um you know if they structured it as if
it was you know some sort of a rental
uh maybe that would be different but
that's not really how it works i'm
buying it i'm using it and if it breaks
i should be able to fix it
um
and
i think i would agree with
representative indrik about the the
issue of of
you know
recycling
um i think
the idea of
tossing out a uh
device that costs in a lot of cases more
than a thousand dollars if it's a cell
phone and then obviously there's other
types of electronics that are even more
expensive
uh just because it doesn't work
even if you have insurance as
representative hunt does
um
to get a new one that that means you're
putting a lot more uh some unrecyclable
stuff into the waste stream and in most
cases
the electronics like that are difficult
if not impossible to really reuse any of
any of the
the devices much less the
contents the materials
and so i i think
making the devices last as long as they
can and certainly there's people who get
new cell phones uh either sell or give
away their old ones because somebody
else can use them and so keeping them in
good repair and using them for as long
as possible i think is good for the
environment good for the economy um and
so i think it makes sense for us to to
move forward with some type of repair
mechanism
so we were talking about who
might do this besides new hampshire and
massachusetts
who of course did the automobile right
to repair and now are fighting about the
next round of that
also had a bill uh this year
that uh was electronic right to repair
i'm not sure i don't believe they
uh
have completed their work on that and of
course
like all the rest of us it's on the
ballot in massachusetts
the the the automobile one is but i'm
talking about the electronics
all right so remember that uh today
we're voting to recommend for future
legislation or not there will be lots of
time to
detail
the pieces
and we have a few more bills to uh to
discuss so
[Music]
representative williams i'm sorry to
interrupt
well i was done
okay thank you uh representative hunt
yeah i just want to respond to uh uh
representative abel's comment
they're not this is not competition
between new hampshire small businesses
against the big nasty corporation in
californ cupertino california
that little small new hampshire company
has every
ability
to become a licensed service center
from apple
and have no problem getting whatever
they need or manuals or whatever detail
what the issue is if i remember the
hearing properly is
they didn't like what the company wanted
to do for service
they wanted to get in there with a
soldering iron
because apple would say is you can
replace the motherboard if it's if
something's not work you're going to
replace the board but we don't want you
in there
touching our technology our board what
we put into it this is not competition
okay the competition is is the example
of what if you're going to say
uh
in my example which is what happens if a
new hampshire corporation that really
has spent a lot of time work to micro
size they wanted taking this technology
and made it so small and so compact they
don't want anybody inside that they
don't want anybody to know what they did
what their their you know magic secret
sauce of how they made it
and this legislation is saying that they
have to hand over information to any
anybody and it could be an illegal could
be a third party you know a fake company
we had we did have a story i remember
the hearing there was somebody who was
using this as a fraudulent you know way
to you know get people to bring in their
computers
to anybody and they're saying it's no if
we're going to do anything like that
we're going to do it on our terms so we
know who the person is and what they are
and whether they're really competent in
doing anything to it so this is this is
not small business competition this is a
small new hampshire business saying is i
i don't want to play by their rules i
don't want i want to i want to service
their product
okay because everybody wants that
product but i don't want to play by the
rules i don't want to pay the licensing
i don't want to have the regulation i
don't have the tools i don't want to
have i mean i just want give me the
manual and that's just not right
thank you representative hunt and
representative van houden
represent van houghton
you're muted
i'm sorry about that
i'll be very quick i think that the
polarization of our discussion right now
shows us that this bill really needs to
be changed in scope in order to go
forward i do i appreciate the the intent
of the bill i appreciate the idea of
small business
moving forward but the fact that we're
so so into the
nitty-gritty of the bill uh in very
polarized fashion i think indicates to
me that this is certainly not ready to
go at least in this fashion it needs to
be fine-tuned it needs to be better
structured in order to make uh the
intent go forward thank you
thank you representative van houten and
before we go to a motion uh
representative osborne are you uh
hearing this
representative osborne uh yes yes thank
you would you just uh tell us uh where
you are so that uh
all the uh eyes will be dotted
yes uh auburn new hampshire home
thank you very much
and uh representative indrik would you
make a motion on house bill 462
gladly i would move that we recommend
future legislation
and i would second that
um and representative weston when you
are ready if you would uh
make the roll call
i'm ready uh chairman williams
yes
representative
gage not here
representative abel
yes
representative bartlett not here
representative herbert
not here out here
representative macbeth
representative maclath votes yes
representative van houghton
yes um
i will vote yes
representative fargo
you're muted
yes
representative indrip
representative wesson i vote yes
representative hunt
no
representative sanborn not here
representative
osborne representative plummer
no
representative barnes
representative
no
representative warden
and chairman butler
yes
eight
to six
recommended uh on uh house bill 462
passes
thank you for that discussion
and
uh we'll move on to house bill
relative to the liability of directors
and officers of new hampshire non-profit
corporations
and
[Music]
i'll begin this discussion um i'm i'm
pretty sure that
representative
ebel and or her husband
uh are in the
attendees the audience and if either of
you
would like to speak which i am hoping
you would um please uh raise your hand
um
as i recall the discussion on this bill
um it is an attempt uh to simply
provide more protection for the
directors and officers of
uh small
new hampshire non-profit corporations
obviously uh during the discussion there
were
serious challenges to
the way this uh
the way this uh bill was
structured
but that the intent uh still seems to be
something worth pursuing
and hopefully uh during this discussion
we can
sort out whether or not that means that
we should
move ahead with recommending this for
future legislation
representative representative macbeth
i would defer to uh
representative abe
i would defer to representative ebel if
she would like to speak first
thank you
um
ms smarling i don't see who has raised
their hand it's representative evil and
i will um
bring her
she's she's allowed to talk as long as
she
unmutes
great representative ebal thank you
there you go
okay um well thank you very much and uh
thank you representative macbeth um
uh i i am indeed here with my husband
steve root who is much more of an expert
on these matters than i am but i
appreciate the
committee considering going forward with
this bill
in um in some fashion because i do
believe that the non-profits and the
directors who serve on those non-profits
on a voluntary basis
deserve
at least some limitations on their
liability without a lot of direct
intervention if they don't know what the
law is
at a particular time so with that with
the with the chairman's permission i'd
like to turn um this over to my husband
steve root
so
he is there with you and he is in the
room with me yes
great um
we will uh yes go ahead
mr root
uh thank you
uh chairman butler it's good to see the
representatives in good health
um
so
our proposal the this bill would have
changed the
uh structure
of uh limitation of liability for
directors and officers of non-profits
from what is currently in place which
requires a
a provision to be added to the articles
of agreement of these organizations um
in my experience a great number of the
states uh seven or eight thousand
non-profits have not done this
and i believe it's mainly just an
oversight on their part
however
when we propose to change the uh the
default provision so that
directors and officers would have this
protection
the division of charitable trusts
mr donovan
pointed out that that
one effect of this could be to make it
more difficult for his
his charitable trust unit to uh
protect organizations where directors or
officers had uh failed to meet their
standards of care
um in in looking at this he has a
legitimate concern his his charitable
trust units which by the way is
the oldest of its kind in the country
and very experienced uh
performs a really important function
uh
it is a very small minority of our
organizations that that fail to meet the
standards but when they do
the charitable trust unit is able to
uh hold directors and officers
accountable
and in many cases make a recovery for
the organization that that can be very
important in salvaging a very bad
situation
those recoveries are frequently paid for
out of dno insurance proceeds and in
fact that uh in the examples that mr
donovan pointed out i think
all of them
the recoveries were from dno insurance
and so his point is that if you if any
organization
merely eliminates liability of directors
and officers
one effect of that can be that it's
letting the dno insurance
that's being bought and paid for by the
organization somewhat off the hook so
i've looked at this
and have discovered that in a number of
states i can identify at least four
the way this issue has been resolved is
to provide that a limitation of
liability is automatic
but does not extend to any coverage that
would be provided by a dno insurance
policy
so in this way there there remains a
recovery now i would point out there are
a lot of nonprofits in the state that
are very small that that
can't really afford dno insurance it's
not inexpensive and and so you have to
be of a certain size to have it and so
in some cases uh uh
an exception that says dno insurance
liability would remain and
uh wouldn't change the outcome but
i i believe there's a middle road here
that answers uh mr donovan's concerns uh
but it also goes to the point that
that uh was really the point of the bill
which is to
uh uh provide protection for directors
and officers from
uh excessive personal liability
thank you very much for that testimony
um
and uh representative macbeth uh your
hand is still raised would you like to
comment now
yes thank you mr chairman so i'm i
really um i'm so grateful that the
the prime sponsor of the bill this
willingness to work through the
identified issues with the attorney
general um is very important i think
that the liability of our non-profit
board of directors is really critical of
importance here in
portsmouth just recently we had a
non-profit pop-up new hampshire pop-up
portsmouth that
really got into some issues
and they even had they did have an
attorney on their board but um
i think shielding these people from not
all liability but um you know these
pop-ups i mean these non-profits are
small and they can't afford an attorney
a lot of times so to have this
limitation automatically
within the um you know the the um
bylaws would be very important so and i
also want to remind my colleagues when
we recommend this for
further legislation it might not be that
because of kovid i mean we're we're i
want us to think long term i mean it
might not be that this is the most
critical thing right now for all of us
but this is an issue that does need
further
legislation so i would ask you to
consider that when you're making your
vote because this is something that
needs to be addressed whether it can be
addressed you know starting in january
or the next or the next session but it
is a really important issue
you know to our communities thank you
i appreciate that and i see a hand from
representative bartlett representative
bartlett uh
before you uh make your commentary if
you would just let us know uh where
you're calling from and if there's
anybody in the room thank you i
appreciate your
patience i had an appointment that i
couldn't get out of um
i'm christy bartlett i am
calling in from my home office
and nobody else is in the room
and that's in what town oh in concord
sorry
thank you
and did you want to comment on this bill
yes um in full disclosure i serve on two
non-profit boards one for the women's
club of concord and um
one for the merrimack valley daycare
center neither of which are a flush
we're all volunteers
we
certainly
try to make decisions carefully
because we have fiduciary
responsibilities
but i think that this legislation would
be really helpful for us and i will vote
to recommend for further legislation
thank you
seeing no further hands i don't know
representative macbeth you seem to have
walked away from your uh desk
uh
representative hunt has his hand
representative hunt uh got his hand up
before you came back
thank you uh well i i don't want to
leave this thing uh
quickly um so for disclosure i am uh
the treasurer of the rindge historical
society
and the 1894 association which is part
of the library uh and my wife is
president of the rings chamber of
commerce having said that i have
absolutely had a conversation with the
charitable trust division and they said
this bill is chasing a problem that
doesn't exist and the last thing you
need to do is create some legal
complication that will vulnerably put
some non-profit into the exposure of
of some lawsuits
and um and so you know at the end of the
day if there's malfeasance going on
there um i don't think we want to
protect anybody
we want to make sure that that person
who who is stealing money or doing
whatever they're doing inappropriately
is prosecuted to the full extent of the
law
and the last thing we need to do is
muddle the waters with this this uh this
legend you know this potential
legislation when clearly there's doesn't
there has not been any evidence there's
a problem with our
current situation our current law and we
want to call it case law it really is
what it is
so thank you raising a problem doesn't
exist thank you and representative abel
has his hand up i'm sorry representative
macbeth we almost got a motion in there
representative abel yes thank you
in this case i agree completely with
representative hunt
i'm
quite concerned that
uh
removing liability
um but
it's it's
not the same as re you know i mean
requiring uh
uh insurance uh there are a lot of gray
areas i also don't recall there being a
lot of uh
uh
demand for for this legislation
on the part of nonprofits and so i think
there's just a way too too much to go
for us to recommend it fine
thank you representative patusik
uh thank you mr chair uh
to be noticed uh i'm also on a uh the
very homegrown uh
board of directors
uh and all honesty and i agree with
representative hunt that it's an answer
looking for a question
thank you
representative macbeth would you uh make
a motion on this bill yes thank you mr
chairman i make a recommendation that
this legislation be considered for
additional legislation for this issue
this matter
thank you and representative bartlett
would you second
yes
thank you
and uh madam clerk when uh you are ready
please call the roll on uh recommended
for future legislation
on
uh house bill 1267
vice chairman
yes
representative gage not here
representative abel no
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes
representative van houten yes
representative fargo
fargo sorry yes
representative indirect
yes
representative weston
no representative
representative hunt
no
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
no
representative plummer
representative barnes
no
representative petusik no
representative warden
i am joining my friend and western
voting no
thank you
vice chairman butler
yes
so the motion uh fails
7 eight seven in favor and eight against
is there another motion to be made
i'll make it
representative hunt
moves uh not recommended for future
legislation and represented the two six
seconds
and the clerk when she is ready will
call the rule
hold on yep
another sheet here
all right uh vice chairman williams
representative gitch not here
representative abel
yes
representative bartlett no
representative herbert not here
uh representative mcmas
representative macbeth votes no
representative van houghton no
representative fargo
no
representative
yeah
representative weston
representative hunt
yes
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
yes
plummer
plumber votes yes
representative barnes
yes
representative batusik yes
representative warden
yes
chairman butler
no
and so house bill 1267
is not recommended for future
legislation
the vote is eight in favor and seven
again
and uh representative hunt if you would
uh write a blurb on that that would be
great
um
and uh we'll move on to house bill 1397
relative to the referral of debts for
collection
and
[Music]
i don't see any hands but i'm wondering
representative williams if you would uh
talk a bit about this bill before we
have a vote
sure so
this bill
proposed that there needs to be an
affirmative
connection between the debt collector
and the debtor
prior to collection efforts starting so
that would require
someone
going to their house and sticking
an envelope on the door
uh or uh you know some other sort of
affirmative
connection between them
so that uh i think that
the concept was that uh some people
actually aren't aware that
there
that there's a debt to be collected
and so
they the sponsors wanted to have uh
to be sure that the person who was the
debtor uh was aware that collection
effort was starting
um
well you know i i certainly understand
the
the issue of you know having somebody
harass you call you all hours of the day
or night
uh you know robo calls and recordings
and things like that can be very
annoying
uh
it isn't clear to me that this
type of process
actually makes the debt collection
uh
any easier on the debtor
um
i i would
be quite happy to see us come up with
something that actually did make it
reduce the number of uh telephone calls
that people got
because i think
robo calls and those kinds of things are
annoying i mean i don't get
deader calls but i get lots of them
trying to sell me extended car
warranties for some reason
um
but um i think
it wasn't clear to me that this bill was
actually going to work and this of
course was before uh the the pandemic
and i'm sure
nobody wants somebody coming up on their
front porch and knocking on their door
or or even sticking an envelope on their
door uh at this point of course
hopefully we'll be past that point at
some point
thank you very much seeing no other
hands represent williams would you make
a motion sure i i would move that we
do not recommend this uh bill for future
legislation
and do i have a second second
i'm sorry i don't know where that came
from
representative
thank you
but it doesn't matter whatever
okay
um
so when the clerk is ready if you would
call a roll on not recommended for
future legislation on house bill 1397
vice chairman williams
yes representative giggs not here
representative abel yes
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative indrik
yes
representative weston yes representative
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
i vote yes and also need to disclose
that i do own a debt collection agency
representative plummer
yes
representative barnes
representative petusik yes
jordan
yes
chairman butler yes
that would be
15-3
i'm sorry um
that must be those virtual people
exactly
so let's move on to a discussion of
house bill 1508 relative to paper
receipts
and representative weston
um
yes i think that we're all we're moving
in this direction we're all having this
experience where we order we uh make a
purchase with a credit card and
they say do you want me to email it or
do you want a paper receipt
so that's happening more and more
uh with this bill though we ran into a
problem because it requires
uh businesses with more than 20
employees
to not give a receipt unless it's asked
for
and the real issues came up when we were
talking about cast cash-based
transactions
um and one of the people who testified
mentioned that the
um
that
return fraud is really a growing
business and something like 21 of the
returns
uh that don't have a receipt are
fraudulent
so um
you know this this may be something
that's going to evolve in time but i
think at this point um it's a little
premature there are a lot of people who
are still
not comfortable with the idea of not
having a receipt and there's too much
fraud
thank you representative hunt
yeah thank you uh so you know maybe it's
kind of code or whatever but i i don't
think i have had any transactions at all
in which they did not ask me
if i wanted to waive the receipt
so um i think that this legislation is
really not necessary anymore that
businesses are more than willing not to
print the receipt for you
excellent thank you
seeing no other hands uh representative
uh weston would you make a motion yes i
recommend
this not be uh
considered for future legislation
thank you representative hunt would you
second that yes i will
thank you remember fargo wanted a second
oh i'm sorry well
i'm sorry
uh represent weston if you would call
the role
uh vice chairman williams
yes
representative gage not here
representative abel
uh yes yes
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative indrik
yes
representative weston yes representative
hunt
yes
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne yes
representative plummer
yes
representative barnes
2-6
yes representative warden
yeah
damon butler
yes
that would be
18 to nothing
no 15 to
nothing you
thank you
and uh we will move on to house bill
relative to the labeling and sale of
hemp products containing cbd
are there any committee members who want
to speak to this issue
representative van houden
thank you mr chair um
this is ordinarily the type of bill that
i would say has too many unanswered
questions and too much uh that needs to
be ironed out before it goes forward
however i am aware and i don't know if
he's on if if jerry carrick is on if
representative connecticut
um
after simply saying that the revisions
that i've seen him make um predispose me
to believe that he can make this happen
and so i would be willing to add to
recommend that we move this forward on
the basis of the integrity that i have
seen
to already make a better bill even
though it has stalled and so i will
defer to representative clerk if he's
available to address the issue
he has his hand in the air
thank you representative are there any
other committee members who want to
speak before we go to members of the
audience
so
uh
uh at first i have um
i'm sorry
first i have cheryl strong murray
from murray powell or strong murray
powell
um
maybe you could clarify who you are
they're gone
they are gone i
oh there she is yeah she's back he is
okay good
yes hello everyone um this is cheryl
murray powell esquire i'm a cannabis and
agricultural attorney
and i'm here to first say thank you for
your concern and passion for consumer
safety
i'm here representing the hemp
industries association's legal defense
fund as well as my client sunflora also
known as your cbd store
um the hemp industry association has
worked hand-in-hand with legislators
federal agencies for over a decade and
moving forward progressive hemp
legislations while considering
consumer safety
your cbd store they have over 600 stores
in the u.s four stores in the uk and
they're currently going through rigorous
international
registration we believe that this bill
is is a good bill but it can be improved
without the restriction on um
out-of-state manufacturers of cbd being
included
that is overly burdensome
and as it was referenced before we don't
want to create this environment where
it's looked at competitively between
in-state manufacturers and out-of-state
manufacturers
the industry standard is for
an out-of-state manufacturer to meet the
standards of the actual state in
addition to that um there's another uh
level where some states are requiring
that a usda um hemp plan has been
approved by the usda
so we're recommending that we strike
through
that requirement that the
the product has to be manufactured in
state because it's an undue burden and
it actually
will uh restrict the consumers of the
ability to have a free and open market
as well as producers um
the hemp industry we've been growing
we've been progressing we are uh aligned
with making sure we're in compliance
with regulations and we think it would
be a disservice to the consumers of the
state of new hampshire if you restrict
the opportunity to participate and the
involvement of all the knowledge and
experience from out-of-state producers
as far as participating in this robust
industry in new hampshire thank you
thank you and will you be available to
continue to work on this if this bill
should come forward absolutely i work in
a number of states with hand-in-hand
with legislators i was involved with
louisiana i spoke at the georgia
senate ad committee i spoke in the
florida senate ag committee iowa
legislation um i go from state to state
working with legislators that want to do
the right thing but they want to make
sure that they take in all the concerns
of the consumer so i am available as a
resource and i will also share my email
address it's smp
esquire smp e-s-q-u-i-r-e
at outlook.com and again you have the
support of the hemp industries
association
legal defense fund and making sure that
we put out good legislation and that it
doesn't restrict the participation out
of state manufacturers with experience
thank you very much for your uh ability
to be here and to give us commentary
and uh we will move on to representative
konerk thank you
okay
here he is
there we go
okay can you hear me okay
we can okay
yes thank you very much for allowing me
to speak for a moment um first before
you do anything else i have to say i
agree 100 with a previous speaker that
was a drafting error
um what it was that is only supposed to
be any food product containing cbd and
that is because it is fda uh is against
fda rules to transport food with cbd in
it across state lines so the idea is the
cbd can produce anywhere but if it's
going to be added to food it had to be
added here within this um
within this state so that's what that
has to do with so i do agree with her
100 i didn't realize i could go onto
video there we go
so uh let me go back just continuing to
understand that cbd
is really quite a fad drug it does have
some serious effects uh particularly we
are still uncertain about the effects
during pregnancy this bill is really
meant primarily to be a public health
bill to deal with labeling and testing
requirements to be sure that there's a
quality product that does not come in
with pesticides or comes in with no cbd
at all or that we have pregnant or
lactating women taking it until we know
a little bit more about it
so the information you got from the
national products association that was
sent to you just a couple of days ago
discusses the fact that the fda still
has not given any regulatory guidance
that is a problem and that is why i put
in this bill on the state level now
again there were a number of drafting
errors i did send to everybody a
suggested
amendment i did not draft an amendment
because the bill is no longer in my
hands but it's in the committee hands
one was to get to strike the word uh
sorry to add the word food product so
that it is not going to regulate uh
any cbd product sorry it will regulate
but it will not prohibit out of state
products uh there were some other things
that were confusing because uh it was
stated that the lab testing had that the
uh
we had to authorize or certify the lab
that doesn't need to be done there are
certifications for labs we just have to
approve it that was a sticking point
because the amf put in a bunch of money
for being able to figure out how to
certify a lab they do not need to
they're certified federally already
there were some other typos and i also
softened the wording on breastfeeding to
be consistent with the cdc
recommendations and not the text that i
had in there were a few other minor
issues that just had to do with labeling
and there was also another drafting
error uh regarding the registration it
was listed as
75.75 dollars per product
again a number of these things impacted
the fiscal note because
damf thought there's all kinds of things
they had to do now you may recall that
one of the major sticking points is the
dm damf really did not want to have
anything to do with this bill
period that's probably not unreasonable
given the fact that it really is a
public health bill it has to do with cbd
in food and has to do which comes under
dhhs food safety it also is an issue
that it is a drug um cbd and its pure
form epidiolex is actually approved as a
drug it is not regulated though by the
fda in terms of the cbd that we see
being sold at a local gas station so it
is a public health problem it makes much
more sense for it to reside entirely
within dhhs i had split it it went to a
draft or for damf which is partly why
some of the things came through with
some drafting errors that didn't make
sense
so what i would like to do would be
reintroduce the bill with all the
changes that i put in
in the proposed amendment that i sent to
you all i think yesterday
secondly uh get it all into dhhs hands
completely remove damf so they have
nothing to do with it which makes more
sense
thirdly is if necessary increase the
robustness of the
fee per product if necessary in order to
try to make it as close to self-funding
as possible because even though it is
intended to be self-funded there are of
course some minor startup costs with
beginning any kind of a program and
given the budget that could be
conceivably a problem i feel it should
go forward and it really should go
forward simply on the basis of the fact
that we do need to continue to protect
the public health i should disclose that
i currently am the chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board so we take a very strong interest
in trying to understand what the issues
and risks are for therapeutic cannabis
and that would include both thc
and cbd and we are currently working on
our guidance and educational things for
both providers and patients regarding
the what cbd risks are and what do we
know about it during either pregnancy or
lactation right now you can sell
something
first of all you don't even know how
much cbd is in it it isn't required
secondly there's no warning about uh its
impact in pregnancy no warning about
its impact upon other drugs you may take
if you're on a statin many of us are for
high elevated cholesterol it interferes
with the metabolism of that because the
same cytochrome breaks down both so all
these things are real problems these
things need to be
stated you need to know that you're
getting a pure product know what the
risks are and also no unfounded health
claims that's again what this is about
it's a public health bill i would like
to proceed with it next year with all
these multiple changes
thank you very much for your time
thank you representative knurk
and there was one other person in the or
there is one other person in the
audience and you were identified uh a
couple of minutes ago but now it's just
your telephone number
um and so
ms smarling could you
um
i can allow this
phone caller to speak if you'd like
please
the person calling in
hey sorry about that it's kyle circ with
the natural products association uh i
just wanted to echo some of the points
that representative knurk and the
previous speaker had made
this a really great bill from our
standpoint
just a little bit about mpa we're the
largest trade association representing
the dietary supplement and nutritional
care space
we have about 750 members with
several independent health food stores
in the state of new hampshire as well
as a dietary supplement
we've seen cbd
across the country have issues
particularly with labeling as well as
when you are testing products heavy
metals pesticides are a common
theme when you do
analysis of of these products so having
uh labeling requirements uh like what
this bill proposes is a great uh is a
great step and a great requirement to
have so thank you thank you all
thank you for your testimony and uh
representative hunt you have your uh
your hand up yeah great thank you mr
chairman uh so i'm confused because i
thought cbd doesn't do we don't know
doesn't do anything that's why fda
hasn't approved it so
you know i know these guys have gone
offline but
my concern i guess i asked jerry is
so if the intent of the bill is that
there's going to be this whole laundry
list of things that has not been proven
to do
what what is the labelings gonna what's
the labeling going to look like and
what's the labeling requirements but
more importantly i'm what i'm worried
about
is giving the wrong impression that if
the state
says this is okay or something the state
says this is some kind of seal of
approval that's going to tell people
that this stuff is good for something
and i think that's absolutely the wrong
message we want to be sending to anybody
because as far as i know it's it's quack
medicine you know um so the idea of that
they're going to have this long legit i
guess a is i guess you can get jerry
back but is there going to be a long
laundry list of things it does not
do or
how what is this labeling requirements
going to do
and b is isn't he at all concerned that
now this is going to give the wrong
impression to people that this stuff is
is
worthy to buy
thank you
uh
representative hunt
and i am seeing more people in the
audience who want to speak
no i guess
those those hands in the audience need
to be uh lowered
well though they were raised
you know again so
i think that
these are the people that spoke and then
they would answer my question
so the representative from the national
product association would you uh
uh comment
you're back in um you're allowed to
speak
yeah sure
so so in terms of health claims right
now
um
representative hunt is on the right
track there when it when he's uh talking
about you know what are um
claims that cbd products are able to
make right now if you look at all the
warning letters um the fda has issued
four
uh cbd products they do
they do go around um
kind of what claims are being made so
for example products that are saying
that they could uh cure cancer and some
of the more egregious
um claims that are being made i i think
what we've seen
uh in other states
that
kind of
would work here is you know um
not
not um
oh jeez i just lost my train of thought
here for a second
um
yeah sorry about that um so yeah when it
comes to labeling here i i think
as long as these products are um being
labeled with the appropriate amounts of
cbd i think you're on the right track
there
thank you right but they're saying this
i can't it's bad for pregnancy and bad
for statins is that going to say that on
the labels is that what
i guess i'd like to hear representative
kerner is that what he's looking for
well and representative kanerk has
raised his hand so we will uh hear from
him again
represent connerk
okay there we are yeah yeah i i can now
you can you hear me
yes we can okay good um actually what
the what the warning about pregnancy
would be as i say is currently going to
be consonant with what is recommended by
the uh
cdc and that is simply
there may be serious risks to using
products containing cbd if you are
pregnant or breastfeeding so it is not a
long laundry list regarding the health
claims it just says you cannot make
unfounded health claims so
it it doesn't have a laundry list of
things the uh issues too
to suggest
or i should say the positive comments
would be
that you should consult the medical
provider if you're taking this with
other medications and that's because the
interaction we don't want to go through
a laundry list that would be
inappropriate but you should talk to
your provider if you're on
a statin which again a subnet stand
strong number of people are they may
need to adjust their dose a warning to
keep it out of the reach of children and
the most important thing is to label
what the content of cbd is
and to make sure it actually contains
what it is some of it's sold without
even having cdc this does not make any
claims that this is
a
healthful supplement uh there's nothing
that's implicit in that at all the point
is that market is there this is a
booming market what we're trying to do
is protect customers from the snake oil
salesman that say this is good for
everything and even
may make a claim on it saying that it
cures cancer that should simply not be
there
um the other thing is it's important to
understand that it can have up to .3 thc
and if you are in a job that requires a
drug test you should be warned of the
fact that this does contain thc because
you may fail a drug test and get fired
when you've just taken you thought only
cbd
so those are the kind of warnings the
things that have to do with making it
safe uh
not a laundry list of things we don't
know but the things we do know and again
staying consistent with what we have for
warnings from the cdc and uh
to
to for the pregnancy and breastfeeding
because although we do know what all the
details we do have some concerns because
certainly uh whole plant cannabis does
have some very clear deleterious effects
we still have to start to tease out a
little bit more and epidiolex which is
the pure form of cbd has highly
substantial risks that are associated
with it that is generally at a higher
dose and but it is not a risk-free drug
by any means
thank you i'm here for any other
questions you have
thank you representative connerk and
ms strong murray powell
you have raised your hand again
there she is
sorry i had to unmute i i also want to
thank representative hunt for raising
the point about labeling labeling is
extremely important i think there's uh
three key things to think about um one
would be making sure that you link
either by a qr code or by a website
address to the coas which are the
certificates of analysis which will show
that that product has gone to a
third-party test uh testing lab and
they've gone through the rigorous
testing and you can see uh what you will
see is a laundry list of cannabinoids
that are included the fact that that
product does not have lead and solvents
and other contaminants and that it's
safe for for consumers um also you'll
probably see um something indicating
that this product contains a total delta
nine thc concentration that does not
exceed the the federal standard of 0.3
um and and that's really really critical
and then just for accountability sake um
some type of address for the
manufacturing site so that you can
definitely trace it by latching and a
lot and batch number to the person who
is making this available to consumers so
labeling is important you don't have to
have a extremely long label you can link
to the necessary information by qr code
or listing a web address
it's amazing to me that there is that
degree of sophistication in the labeling
and yet the federal government
is not able to
um
participate in this process it's
on a state-by-state basis still
thank you for that uh commentary um and
uh ms darlington uh
in the audience has raised her hand
she
is on the way
thank you
she should be there there she is
ms darlington if you could unmute
yourself and uh give us your thoughts on
this bill
i'm trying to unmute her and i can't
from my end
if you can hear us ms darlington you
need to unmute yourself
wonderful can you hear me can you hear
me now yes
hi great well good afternoon everyone
thank you so much for this meeting we
were very excited to hear all the
conversation about this bill in
particular my name is amanda darlington
i'm with the council for responsible
nutrition we're the leading trade
association on dietary supplements
manufacturer suppliers were based out of
dc and i just wanted to echo
miss
murray's statements as well relabeling
and just wanted to throw in the mix here
that dietary supplements in particular
are comprehensively regulated at the
federal level by the federal by fda and
by ftc and labeling requirements are
comprehensive and
i remember earlier in the hearing as
well just to kind of throw our hat in
crn is advocating very stringently at
the federal level
for fda to appropriately regulate
cbd hemp derived cbd products coming out
of the 2018 farm bills legalization of
hemp and taking it off the controlled
substances list so we would also
encourage the committee and also the
sponsor of the bill if this bill is
reintroduced next year in deference to
the push in congress right now the last
ditch efforts and also
the overall strategy of getting fda to
regulate these dietary supplement
products in particular because there is
a comprehensive regulatory framework
already in place we would
love to speak further with the sponsor
about how that will look and
representative hunt to answer your
question re-labeling requirements it's
another reason why we are all pushing
fda to appropriately regulate these
products because the framework is very
much already in place and if these
products were susceptible to these
regulatory requirements they would be
regulated
thank you very much for your testimony
and thank you for paying attention to
this issue uh in new hampshire
and uh representative van houghton
thank you
thank you yes i did thank you very much
um i appreciate everything that we've
heard some of it is of a complexity that
is a little beyond my pay grade
however i would just like to simplify
to a basic question any one of those who
have spoken from the audience if i could
get an answer from one of you please i
would appreciate that
are we talking about cbd products
currently marketed as dietary
supplements
that
are devoted devoid of this type of
information on the label yet i can still
purchase them today if i wish to do so
and representative knurk has that uh
answer
he's on his way
unmute yourself there we go okay yeah
yeah you can okay um
yes
you can
um and i have uh gone into one of our
local stores picked it up actually when
you stop at um
when i get off exit uh
off route 93 it actually for getting
onto 104 to come home from concord and
you go in the grocery store the uh
little store there associated with the
gas station huge sign right in the door
we sell cbd products i've gone into
health food stores picked them up
uh indeed uh some of them do have some
labeling vermont does have a robust
program so one of the stores in our area
which carries vermont products yes
indeed there is a link with either with
a qr code or or website to be able to
get to this certificate of analysis and
i agree with the comments uh again made
uh by ms strong and that is that we do
need to have
tracking that's available eat with ease
you can't put all this on it i mean the
certificate of analysis which has any
potential toxins and lead and so on and
so forth and the cannabinoid profile
that's too much to stick on the small
bottle that's where you would link to it
with a qr code or some other technique
and also in the proposed amendment i did
have information about the name and
address of the manufacturer as was
brought up because that is important to
be able to track down
and also the date of
manufacture so that you do know and you
can track it if there is a problem all
those are normal public health type of
issues that need to be on this again
those were left out of the original bill
but they're on my list of amendments um
but yes you can buy these right now
and those labeling uh
again the ones that come out of vermont
do have some labels but you do not have
this protection of having the
information available in general because
it is not
required so yes you can get this
thank you representative kanerk and mr
chairman mr chairman i would like to ask
jerry a question directly do you mind if
i um i uh come on live is good
since since he is here uh representative
van houghton also has a question
representative van houghton
um do you mind if representative hunt
gets his question asked or do you want
to
she wants to ask him a question
well actually mine is just a quick
follow-up to representative knurk
please
very quick uh just representative kenner
in the absence
of fda regulations
would you say that it is appropriate
that legislation to somehow get labeling
going forward
is appropriate regardless of how you
work this out in legislation in the next
session uh is that is that the intent
and is that the purpose of what you're
saying today
yes that's always been the primary pro
point of this whole bill is
safety
uh through appropriate labeling of
the appropriate warnings and the
contents
uh so that we are have a product which
we are not
we're not pretending that we authorize
as something that is effective but at
least if you go in to buy it you
actually are getting what you say you
know what you're getting you have
appropriate warnings and you cannot have
claims that are made that are false in
the marketing of it so yes the labeling
requirements really need to be there
thank you representative representative
so so jerry you're a doctor
would you ever recommend
cbc for anything
would you ever recommend this for
anybody yes number
number one it actually is fda approved
uh for the treatment of certain types of
seizures that is a drug called epidialyx
which is the whole fallacy of calling
this a schedule two
material because it's clearly not
schedule two schedule two means there is
no medical value to it it's been
approved by the fda so you have the dea
and the fda
totally taking different sides of what
this is all about and which shows the
insanity of our of our system of not
regulating it appropriately in any case
so cbd
in a prescription form epidiolex is a
normal drug that is used there is some
pretty good evidence though for cbd in a
number of things and we actually
um
processed in the therapeutic canvas
medical oversight board questions about
cbd for a number of other
problems anxiety and insomnia and so on
and they do not require prescription
epidialx which is ghastly expensive
would not be covered for uh other
indications other than pediatric
seizures but there is evidence that this
can be effective for some of these other
disorders not okay so representative
thank you thank you for that answer
let's not uh spend the afternoon on this
representative hunt
one more quick question please yes or no
keep it simple okay
i in my mind
you just said okay but there is a
prescription formula
do we want to confuse consumers
who are buying it at a gas station
that they are buying the same thing
that they could go to a doctor and get a
prescription for
and that by putting a state label on it
and says
well this
product complies
and there you know we you know we
haven't tested it but they tell us this
is what's in it right because we're not
going to actually do the testing okay
we're going to tell you this don't you
think that that gives the consumer the
the wrong impression
that this actually is effective
for whatever they think it is and that
this is a good thing to buy
when they should be not be doing that
they should be going to their physic
their primary care physician and getting
the prescription one
may i answer please
yes first of all
uh
unless they're independently wealthy
they're not going to be able to afford
the prescription form of epidialex for
something else because it will not be
covered by their insurance company for
off-label use that's extremely unlikely
secondly is we are not giving any
authorization it is epidiolex is a
totally different
issue because it is a prescription drug
um the
i do not think this gives any sense that
it's effective for everything because
that claim is not made in fact that's
precisely the part of this bill you
can't make a claim that it's effective
for anything if you wanted to put down
effective procedures if you drink the
whole bottle five times a day that might
be allowable because you might be
getting to the dose epidialx is actually
a very high-dose drug a lot more cbd
than most people would probably take in
a day so we are not giving a stamp of
approval that this is good for
everything that ails you indeed we're
restricting it so people cannot make
that kind of a claim
i think that answers your question i'm
not 100 sure if i did and i should also
say that you ask would i recommend it
it's also important to realize the
over-the-counter cbd is not a
prescription drug it is also not illegal
currently so it can be recommended very
different than therapy to cannabis which
we don't prescribe we just allow a
person to be certified for
so
i am wanting to tie up this conversation
and uh representative abel i'm hoping to
uh get a
uh a motion are you willing to
um uh forego your commentary yes
thank you
uh and ms darling thank you miss
darlington representative van houten
would you make a motion please
yes i i move to recommend this
legislation to go forward in the next
session
thank you and represent bartlett would
you second i seconded it thank you
um and when you are ready representative
weston if you could call the rule
uh vice chairman williams
yes
representative gage not here
representative abel no
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
clerk would you clarify the um motion is
it for recommended for or recommended
against rep recommended for
yes
representative van houden yes
representative fargo yes
representative indrip
yes
representative weston yes representative
hunt
no
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne no
representative plummer
no
representative barnes
representative patusik
no
representative warden
chairman butler
yes
eight
two
seven
yes
that's eight eight in favor and seven
again strip uh
thank you so the motion to
recommend this uh
uh complex bill
is recommended for future legislation
thank you
and
we will move on to
house bill 1588 establishing a mortgage
mediation procedure
and
could i have
some discussion of this bill and seeing
no hands representative williams would
you remind us about this bill
sure thank you mr chairman
um so
uh
when when i
put this bill together uh i obviously
didn't anticipate
uh a pandemic that would have a serious
effect on
new hampshire's economy
but i think that we're going to see
a lot more
foreclosures
going forward as
uh hopefully the
the country and the state uh start
recovering from this it's gonna take a
long time
um and
there will be people who will
have
financial difficulties we'll be out of
work we'll
lose their businesses
and so i think the foreclosure rate is
going to rise significantly
um
that being said i think that um
you know we had a lot of arguments from
the banks on this bill and on the pre my
previous bill on judicial foreclosure
that we don't have foreclosures in new
hampshire that they're few and far
between and when they are
you know it's purely a case of somebody
just not paying their bills
i think
that
that's not the case and certainly won't
be the case going forward and so
i believe that it's important for us to
have some kind of
additional protection
for
people who
fall into this
crevasse
i think that
something
needs to be done certainly there have
been some efforts some emergency efforts
around
for stalling foreclosures or you know
potentially providing some financial
assistance uh through the cares act and
other measures and governor's emergency
orders
but i think uh
long term we're still going to have
issues it's going to be a few years i
think before
the economy fully recovers
and so
having something in place that will
protect
people who
uh end up in foreclosure
uh through
no fault of their own
is important
thank you very much for bringing us uh
the understanding of
the
reason for this bill
representative macbeth has her hand up
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative williams
i agree strongly that this um this is an
important issue that needs to go forward
um we don't know in what form as
representative williams said this is all
evolving now
the committee is aware that there have
been some issues brought before us in
the past
but i think it's going to become more
focused as we get move forward so i i
definitely think um this is a bill uh an
issue that the committee should keep its
eye on and i definitely encourage
everyone to
you know recommend it for further study
and further legislation and further
legislation thank you
thank you and i was a member of
the
mortgage uh
foreclosure study
committee
several years ago
and that was a robust and
valuable discussion
and there are a number of
successful
efforts at helping people who are
approaching and going through
foreclosure
from some mortgage companies but not
necessarily for all
and some uh mortgages are sold and
resold and it the
likelihood that the person who is going
through foreclosure in those situations
who knows uh who they're dealing with uh
can be
uh nine impossible to find to follow the
thread to uh know who to talk to and and
how to get advocacy uh for your
particular situation i think it is well
worth continuing to
explore for those people who
uh uh are likely as representative
williams said uh to end up in a
situation uh in part because of the
pandemic and the economic impact of it
so i would support
that as well
and uh i see a hand
from
mr hale
can we uh hear from him
absolutely
you should be arriving
if you can unmute yourself
there you go
can can you hear me we can excellent
well it's uh it's nice to see everyone
uh i wish i we saw you in person but uh
it's nice to see you all here um yeah i
just wanted to um bring up the point um
and i know it was brought up during
testimony that um our banks are uh you
know to the bill the substance of the
bill is establishing mediation um to
uh modify the loan um i think it during
our testimony we had a banker testified
to the fact that banks are providing um
modifications and uh foreclosure really
is the last
um
last means or
uh last opportunity that they that they
look to seek um and i think to
representative williams point and um you
know during the coven 19 pandemic uh our
our banks and we surveyed our banks uh
it's safe to say that they all are
working with their their homeowners
their borrowers the the folks that they
hold mortgages on to keep them in their
houses through these forbearance
programs and continuing to tailor these
programs in a manner that makes it um
reasonable to pay back uh and what best
fits each one of those uh home buyers um
so
again
as we mentioned in our testimony we
oppose this proposal we'll be opposing
any future proposals because we feel the
industry is already doing what they can
to help the homeowner
stay in their homes and ultimately at
the end of the day um
if when it comes to it uh foreclosure is
the last last uh means so um thank you
for your time i appreciate you allowing
me to speak
thank you mr hale
um and
uh i'm sure that we'll hear from the
banking association and when and if uh
these issues move forward
um and seeing no other hands
representative williams would you up
wait
no there's no reason for you to wait
uh steve
um
you could have raised your hand a few
minutes ago so we knew that you wanted
to speak i'm sorry uh we don't know who
you are
beyond
the first name of steve but would you
like to speak
yes
and if you could identify uh who you're
with or
how you are associated with this issue
i'm steve bauer i'm the executive
director for the mortgage bankers and
brokers association of new hampshire
and
i waited to raise by hand because i
wasn't sure if kurt stratson our
legislative chair was
one of the participants in the meeting
or not
so
i'm really here to echo what ryan's
points are
there are a few statistics for
the foreclosure starts for q quarter one
in 2019 in new hampshire it was
0.17 percent
and the last
recorded
they have is q1 for 2020 it was 0.14
so foreclosures are very low in new
hampshire
and there's a lot of systems now in
place through the gses
cfpb for complaints and things like that
at the federal level
so we just see it as
something that's really not needed here
in new hampshire
and there
if you do go forward with this bill is
written
there are quite a few
difficulties the way it's written
and so i would suggest that that also be
reviewed so
mortgage bankers and brokers association
is in opposition
thank you
thank you for your commentary
now i see no further hands represented
williams would you make a motion
sure i would uh move that this bill be
recommended for further
legislation thank you and i will second
that
um and the clerk will call the role when
she is ready
all right this is for recommended
for further legislation
vice chairman kermit williams
yes
representative gage not here
representative abel
yes
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes
representative indrik
yes
representative weston yes
representative hunt
no
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
no representative plumber
no
representative barnes
representative patusik
no
representative warden
was that a no mark
is that no
no no no no
and chairman butler
yes
nine
two six
it passes
thank you
and uh that was 1588 let's move on to
1680 just a very simple straightforward
bill
relative to the collection of personal
information by businesses
[Music]
and
uh
representative indrik even though your
hand isn't up i would hope that you
would um remind us of this bill
and
it's intense
uh sure mr chair thank you
as introduced uh the bill is actually
based off of the california uh data
privacy law that passed a couple years
ago and went into effect this year
we had subsequently discussed an
amendment uh which i believe most of the
committee members will recall
that sought to take a smaller more
bite-sized approach
dealing with internet service providers
and basically empowering consumers to
first of all know what data is collected
and then
empowering them with an opt-in
right
where they would their personal
data would not be sold
unless they opted into that sale
this is based on a law that has passed
in maine and i believe went into effect
this summer and went through a court
challenge
that is still proceeding but it passed
the first hurdle
and they did the court ruled that there
was no primo fascia
free speech issue
and it is proceeding accordingly so
anyway as
everybody recalls in 2018 80 percent of
new hampshire voters
agreed to amend the new hampshire
constitution
to instantiate a right to privacy which
has had a long history in our
uh wider jurisprudential history uh
dating back to at least brandeis in the
late 19th century
and i think it's incumbent upon
us short of any action at the federal
level
to do our best to empower consumers here
in the state to exercise that right in
commercial transactions
thank you very much representative
endrick
i am seeing no other hands
and that being the case uh
representative indrick would you make a
motion
i would gladly recommend further
legislation on this important issue
thank you and i would gladly second
and representative weston when you are
ready please call the roll
okay this is for recommend for correct
um vice chairman williams
yes
representative gage not here
representative abel yes
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
yes representative endrick
yes
representative weston yes
representative hunt
i can't hear you i'm sorry
sorry
stop
no there you are
one more time
no
i heard it
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
no
representative plummer
representative
yes
no
representative warden
and chairman butler
yes
that
recommended uh succeeds ten to five
and we'll go on to our last bill uh of
the day and of the year uh house bill
16. yeah house bill 1690 prohibiting
paper billing fees
and seeing
no one
we have
someone in the audience who would like
to speak to this bill
and
we can always comment later if we choose
to so uh
ms smiling if you would let mr corcoran
uh in to speak
good afternoon chairman butler
uh my name is john corcoran i work for
the department of transportation and i'm
in my hooksett office and i'm
by myself
thank you
the department of transportation opposes
this bill
the reason being is that we operate our
easy pass system
and it's operated through our vendor
cubic transportation
and as part of a ezpass account the
terms and conditions we um charge for um
statement fees when they're mailed to
them
when somebody first signs up for an
account we the first year of their roll
the customers receive four quarterly
statements mailed to them at no charge
starting in the second year
all the customers are opt-in to
electronic mail statements unless they
want paper
when they want paper statements we
charge them a dollar per month if it's
an individual account or two dollars for
a business account
we also provide them two
cds if they want their statement on cds
and that's three dollars
a month
at any time the customer is allowed to
go back to the email statements
and they're also
able to get their statements on the web
and print them them out on the web too
the statement charge is to help us
offset for the cost of paper the cd the
envelope and the postage
for the past four fiscal years
fiscal year 17
we collected 31 31 000
in statement fees
since we were 18 we collected around 46
fiscal year 19 it was around 68 000 and
fiscal year 20 was around 73 000
um this bill will impact us in revenue
and in our budget um we recommend we
oppose the bill
um some things that we would have to do
if this bill was passed we'd have to
revise our easy pass system the software
which would cost us money the
applications and the terms and
conditions
this will also as mentioned would
increase our budget in our contract with
cubic in order to pay for the paper the
cds the envelopes and the postage and it
will also a possibility of a more
further impact our budget if customers
know these are free they may be
requesting this a lot more
thank you
thank you for your testimony
you're welcome
and representative van houghton has uh
some comments thank you mr chair may i
address something to mr corcoran who
just testified please
uh you can and mr corcoran if you're
willing uh raise your hand again and
we'll
uh
get you back in so that you can respond
to representative van houden
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for helping us to understand the
economics of what's going on here this
is a question that might be difficult
for you to answer but for the most part
how would you characterize the people
who are getting the paper statements are
they typically elderly are they
typically uh non-computer literate to
the best of your knowledge how would you
characterize that population please
um i'm unable to characterize it because
on the ez pass statements there is no
knowledge of
you know
somebody's age gender all that
um i do know
um
there's like 956 business accounts that
opt into this
and there's like 780
um individual accounts that up into it
and i can tell you a lot of people who
opt into it the reason they tell us is
because
they need it for their taxes and stuff
like that
or expenses with their company
thank you
and mr corcoran hang around just in case
there are other questions representative
macbeth uh would you like to comment
thank you mr chairman and not i
appreciate um mr cochran's comments my
concerns don't really
address his concerns i i want uh to
express in my my legal practice i'm
honored to represent some court
appointed
clients and
this is the only part of my practice
that uh people do request um paper
copies or need paper copies from the
court and these are my most fragile my
elderly or disabled or
um
in poverty clients their clients that
don't have computers aren't don't have
access to email
don't have access to a printer even if
they do have some type of uh
email or
internet capacity on their phones they
they drive to my portsmouth office from
places all over stratford and rockingham
county just to sign a document that i
printed out and left for them during
this covet time so
i really feel that this legislation
while
you know in the um context that um uh
the department of transportation has
concerns certainly the clients i'm
talking about don't even have easy
passes or perhaps not even vehicles that
they could drive to the library and get
something printed off from their cell
phone so i i do think this is an issue
that needs further study i feel like it
falls on
the most vulnerable and fragile
financially in our communities and i
think it's a cost that we all should
bear
i'm willing to bear the cost of printing
off for these people so that it's not a
spiral of increased fares and compounded
fines um so it is a bill that i do think
has an issue i think has
a lot of worth to it again may not go
this time but it is something that i'd
hate to see the committee recommend is
not an issue that we need to look at
just because it might not affect us
thank you
thank you representative williams
thank you mr chairman um
i i think this bill uh like some of the
other ones that we've discussed the last
two days
has a kernel of value but structurally
doesn't work
um this one especially because it's part
of the consumer protection act
and as we as those of you who have been
in this committee for a while no the
consumer protection act
really
requires the attorney general to enforce
and the attorney general is not going to
act on behalf of individual
consumers
if there is a
opportunity for a large tort case
uh they might step in but otherwise
you're you're kind of on your own and
for
uh paper billing fees you're not going
to spend what it costs to go to
superior court so
this is kind of unenforceable the way
it's written
uh the second element of of it being
part of the consumer protection act is
that banks are exempt
um and
i think one of in the testimony that i
recall one of the
places where there was the most
complaints were the idea that you know
you have a checking account and if you
want paper versions of your
uh
monthly statements you have to pay for
those
um but this wouldn't apply to banks
because they're exempt from consumer
protection so
i
while i would agree with uh
representative macbeth that you know
there there ought to be options for
people who
have difficulty either obtaining things
electronically because they
either don't have the equipment or the
knowledge
and also be so that people don't
have to pay for things that they normal
that they in the past were able to get
for free
uh and therefore you know add an extra
burden to their
uh expenses
um
i think
somebody has to come up with a totally
different way of structuring this and
i'm just not really sure what that is
thank you
and uh in our audience is uh
representative
walls mary beth walls uh represent mr
corcoran thank you for uh your
commentary i think uh
uh we have no more questions uh
regarding your testimony
so my
is it my turn
it is your turn thank you um i'd like to
uh piggyback on what representative
mcpheeth has said um
i signed on to this bill i'm not the
prime sponsor i'm a co-sponsor but i
signed on to this bill pretty quickly
when i learned about it because i think
charging for paper statements is really
just a tax on the poor and on the
elderly on those that have for either
economic reasons or because of their age
or even in some cases because of
disability not been able to adapt to
the electronic age like most of us have
and all of us here sitting on this call
obviously have been able to figure that
out and i think that's just wrong and so
i would like to see this proceed
i think there are ways to do it perhaps
we exempt government agencies if i mean
it's obviously a significant money maker
for the department of transportation as
somebody who sits on finance i know how
desperately the department of
transportation needs money and i support
anything that gets them money almost
but i think that there are ways to do it
i don't sit on your committee and i
don't fully understand representative
williams concerns about it being part of
the consumer protection act but it seems
to me that there has to be a way to do
this perhaps outside the consumer
protection act we can deal with
legislative services but i do think that
we should recommend this for further
legislation and i think that we should
be going forward with it perhaps in a
new form now that we understand some of
the challenges but i do think that it's
something that should be brought back
thank you very much for that commentary
any questions for representative walls
before uh
she uh goes back into the audience
seeing no more questions thank you
representative walls
and
i see no more hands although i do want
to let you know that
representative wazir
who was a prime sponsor uh
says that her kids are crying in the
background so she can't join us
but that she hopes that we will support
the bill
and
that
she believes that the
like representative walls that the costs
are
unnecessary and prohibitive
and uh
considering that
um
[Music]
i will move uh that we recommend 1690
for future legislation
is there a second
a second
representative anne houghton seconds
and uh representative weston if you
would
uh
call the role on recommending 1690 for
future legislation
uh vice chairman
yes
representative
here representative abel
yes
excuse me yes
representative bartlett yes
representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes thank you
representative van houghton
yes
representative fargo yes
representative endrick
yes
representative weston yes
representative hunt
no
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
uh to save the trees no
representative plummer
no
representative
no thank
you representative warden
[Music]
and chairman butler
yes
sucks
so that is recommended for future
legislation the vote is nine to six
um
thank you all uh this uh discussion uh
reflects
the respect that we have for each other
and
the ability that we have to
really elucidate the issues and make our
positions known
i really appreciate all the work that we
have done over this past couple of years
and
thank you for your guidance and your uh
leadership over the past two years and
we're going to miss you
thank you yes we will thank you thank
you i will miss you too
you'll you'll still be here you'll be
back
uh maybe
we'll see
um thank you all and unless there are
further comments we will uh end this
meeting take care
thank you take care all right